>> WEEK 7.
MAN, THIS SEASON IS FLYING
HAPPY NFL SUNDAY, EVERYBODY.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE B/R
BETTING SQUAD RIDE LIVE FROM
THE BLEACHER REPORT, HAVING
BEEN PRESENTED BY DRAFT KINGS.
MY NAME IS CONNOR ROGERS,
ALONGSIDE MR. WINNERS ONLY,
GREG IVORY.
GREG, HOW ARE WE FEELING?
ARE WE FEELING GENEROUS TODAY?
>> HEY, CHRISTMAS IS COMING.
HALLOWEEN SEASON IS UPON US.
WE ARE GIVING OUT CANDY, AND
GIFTS.
WHY NOT GIVE OUT HOODIES, RIGHT,
CONNOR?
WHY NOT GIVE OUT HOODIES?
WHY NOT?
FIRST OF ALL, FIRST OF ALL,
CONNOR, I AM SO SORRY.
I HAVE TO INTRODUCE THE NEW
PEOPLE TO THE SHOW, THE PEOPLE
WHO COME BACK TO THE SHOW, THE
TABLES.
RIGHT HERE, I HAVE TO INTRODUCE
YOU GUYS, THIS IS THE HANDY
DANDY IPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET YOUR
HOODIES, YOUR JERSEYS.
THIS IS HOW YOU GET TAPPED INTO
THE SHOW.
I AM HERE, AND I SEE JTNDP0, I
LOVE THAT TAKE, SHOUT OUT TO
YOU JT FOR MVP ZERO, YOU ARE
GETTING A HOODIE.
CONNOR, LET'S GET THIS THING
GOING.
>> FEELS GOOD.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BACK WITH THE
IPAD, NOT THE IPHONE.
I FEEL LIKE IT WILL POP OFF A
LITTLE BIT MORE TODAY.
THIS IS THE SHOW, WHERE WE WANT
TO BET TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
THAT'S WHY WE ASK YOU ON SOCIAL,
IN THE APP, WHO ARE YOUR LOCKS
OF THE WEEK TO GET TO THE END
ZONE FOR WEEK 7 ON THIS NFL
SUNDAY?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE MOST
POPULAR PICKS YOU HAVE SENT US.
NO SURPRISE, APPETITE, RIGHT?
KAMARA, TRAVIS KELCE, DEVONTAE.
YOU SEE THOSE 3 NAMES EVERY
SINGLE WEEK.
AARON JONES, WHO HAD HIS 3RD
TOUCHDOWN GAME THIS YEAR, DJ
MOORE TAKING ON THAT SECONDARY,
OUR SQUAD RIDE LEADER, COOPER
ATE THAT UP LAST WEEK, LAMAR
JACKSON, FORMER MVP.
WE KNOW WHAT HE CAN DO ON THE
GROUND.
JOE MIX IN WITH THE SURPRISING
BENGALS, AND THEN PLUS 240 ON
THE BOTTOM OF THE BOARD, ZACK
ERNST.
PEOPLE MIGHT BE FEELING GOOD
ABOUT HIS DESTINATION, ARIZONA,
WITH ANOTHER MVP FRONT RUNNER
NAMED KYLER MURRAY, WITH KLIFF
KINGSBURY.
SO, A LOT OF FUN TOUCHDOWN
SCORES ON THE BOARD TODAY.
TO GET THINGS STARTED HERE,
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
OUR FAVORITE LOCK LEGEND VIDEOS
FROM LAST WEEK.
>> AT HOME DEPOT, WE ARE TRYING
TO GET YOU GUYS ON LOCK ANYTIME
WE SCORE.
>> 3 JARS OF PEANUT BUTTER,
JUDGE STEVE.
[APPLAUSE] >> ALL RIGHT.
[NOISE] AARON JONES, PLUS 110,
THE PRICE IS RIGHT.
>> OH, WHAT IS THIS?
>> ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN SCORER
KAREEM HUNT, LET'S HAMMER THAT,
BOYS.
>> COOPER KUPP, FORWARD,
GUARANTEED VERSUS THE GIANTS.
>> ALL RIGHT GREG, TELL THE
PEOPLE WHAT YOU ARE HOOKING
THEM UP WITH TODAY.
>> I AM NOT ONLY GIVING HOODIES
OUT TODAY, CONNOR.
I AM ALSO GIVING AWAY NOT ONE,
BUT 2 NFL JERSEYS.
ONE GOES OUT TO THE WINNING
LOCK LEGEND.
THE OTHER GOES OUT TO A LUCKY
COMMENTER LIKE YOU.
SO DO NOT GO ANYWHERE.
STAY TAPPED IN.
GET INTO THE COMMENTS, DO WHAT
YOU ARE DOING.
IF YOU NEED A JERSEY OR A
HOODIE, I NEED GIFTS, I NEED
EMOJIS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, I NEED
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
I ACTUALLY PUT THAT, YOU GUYS
FLOOD THE COMMENTS WITH WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE?
I AM GIVING A HOODIE OUT TO
SOMEBODY THAT SAYS WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE.
CONNOR, LET'S GO.
>> LET'S GET INTO IT.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, SPEAKING
OF THOSE LOCKED, WE HAVE 4
LEGENDARY PICKS TO SHOW YOU,
LAST ONE STANDING WILL BE OUR
WEEK 7 SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
LET'S NOT WASTE ANY TIME.
FIRST PITCH COMES FROM JOHN
HURDLE, WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY, JOHN?
>> BLACKJACK IS A LOCK.
SO IS DAVANTE ADAMS, TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN, WEEK 7, NFL.
LET'S GO!
>> THE BLACKJACK LEGEND, GOING
WITH DAVANTE ADAMS?
I LIKE THAT SET UP!
FIRST DECISION OF THE DAY,
FIRST CHALLENGE OF THE DAY,
LET'S GET OUR 2ND PITCH FROM
NICK JONES, 30 OH 5.
>> LET'S GO,.
BABY HERE I AM AT THE TREE OF
KNOWLEDGE.
SUNDAY WILL BE THE ANNIVERSARY
OF THE PLANTING OF THE TREE OF
KNOWLEDGE, SO LET'S GO AHEAD
AND GIVE YOU SOME BLOCKS.
RIGHT HERE.
IN ALL OF ITS GLORIOUS-NESS.
I WILL PULL DOWN A LEAF, REALLY
QUICK.
OH, WHAT IS THAT?
D. J. MOORE, ANYTIME,
TOUCHDOWN.
LET'S GO, BABY!
>> ALL RIGHT.
YOU HEARD THE FIRST 2 PITCHES,
YOU GOT DAVANTE ADAMS FROM
BLACKJACK LEGEND AND THEN YOU
GOT THE TREE OF KNOWLEDGE,
GOING WITH D. J. MOORE.
GREG, ARE YOU FEELING STRONG
ABOUT EITHER OF THESE?
>> WELL, CONNOR ... I DO NOT
KNOW.
LET ME TAP IN WITH.
PEOPLE GET IN THE COMMENTS,
GUYS, TELL ME WHO YOU SHOULD GO
WITH.
DAVANTE ADAMS, D. J. MOORE, BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY, I ASKED YOU
GUYS TO SAY WINNERS ONLY.
CONNOR, THE COMMENTS ARE
FLOODING WITH COMMENTS ONLY,
BUT SHOUT OUT TO YOU, YOU'VE
GOT, HE GOT THE ROCK LIFTING UP
THE PEOPLES CHAMPIONS SAYING
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE TREE OF KNOWLEDGE OVER
HERE.
I LOVE THAT VIDEO, LOVE THAT
VIDEO.
HE, HE, HE, HE BRIEFED IT UP
REALLY WELL.
A CINEMATIC PIECE, IN FACT.
LOVE THE VIDEO.
THE PICK?
DON'T REALLY LOVE IT LIKE HOW I
LOVE THE DAVANTE ADAMS PLAY
OVER HERE.
JUST KIND OF CONFUSED, KIND OF
CONFUSED AS TO HOW BLACKJACK
HAS 21.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE HAS 19.
HOW DOES THIS ADD UP TO 17?
THIS DOES NOT ADD UP TO 17 AND
DAVANTE ADAMS, BUT HE IS NOT
CONFUSED ABOUT THE PICK.
AARON RODGERS, HE LOOKS AT 17 A
LOT THROUGHOUT THE GAME.
SO, I LOVE MY CHANCES OF HIM
SCORING A TOUCHDOWN.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO OVER
HERE, CONNOR?
YOU KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO?
HERE IT SAYS MINUS 165?
IT WILL NOT STAY LIKE THAT,
CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I AM WITH YOU ALL OF THE
WAY.
LET'S GO WITH THE TARGET
MONSTER, DAVANTE ADAMS.
LET'S GET THAT MINUS 165 A
LITTLE BIT CLOSER TO EVEN
MONEY.
I THINK THAT THE COMMENTS WOULD
LOVE THAT.
GREG, RIGHT NOW, I JUST DO NOT
TRUST SAM DARNOLD TO GET D. J.
MOORE TO THE END ZONE.
EVEN AGAIN, A WEEK GIANTS TEAM,
I DON'T THINK THIS IS A LOT.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT DAVANTE
ADAMS AND AARON RODGERS, THAT
IS AS CLOSE TO A LOCK AS THINGS
CAN GET, NO MATTER WHAT THOSE
ODDS SAY.
BUT HEY, I DO NOT GET TO DECIDE
THIS ROUND, LET'S LET THE
PEOPLE DECIDE.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
>> CONNOR, I AM BACK INTO THE
HANDY DANDY, BACK INTO THE
HANDY DANDY.
OH, MCMAHON 42, HE IS SPANNING.
US HE SAYS, D. J. MOORE IS A
LOCK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, NO HOODIE FOR
THE SPAM, NO HOODIE FOR THE
SPAM.
BUT, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
LOVE THE PICK.
I HAVE GOT DAVANTE ADAMS LOCKED
IN WINNERS ONLY.
LET'S GO, BABY.
LOCKED.
TIM DOG 23-20.
IT IS FELT K3N K3N DOG 23-20,
DAVANTE ADAMS HE'S A LOCK, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
CONNOR, I WILL GIVE AWAY ONE
MORE, CONNOR.
HERE WE GO.
I SEE A LOT OF DAVANTE ADAMS.
I WILL BE HONEST, I SEE A LOT
OF DAVANTE ADAMS.
AND HERE WE GO, J.J. SNELL SAYS
ADAMS, ADAMS, ADAMS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, J.J.'S.
NOW YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE, CONNOR.
IT APPEARS, IT IS VERY APPARENT
IN THE COMMENTS, IF YOU LOOK AT
THEM.
IT IS DEVONTAE ALL THE WAY.
THE BLACKJACK, LEGEND DAVANTE
ADAMS AND JOHN HURDLE IS MOVING
ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> IT FEELS LIKE WE HAVE A
BLOWOUT.
FIRST FOUND BELONGS TO JOHN
HURDLE.
2 CHALLENGES REMAINING,.
THOUGH HE HAS A LONG WAY TO GO
IN OUR NEXT PITCH, IT COMES
FROM W TRAMMEL, ALWAYS BRINGS
THE HEAT, A FAMILIAR FACE ON
THE SHOW.
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT, W TRAMMEL?
>> WE ARE HERE WITH AN ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN HIT ONE OF
THESE BOYS.
LAMAR JACKSON, LOCKING IT IN!
NATHAN >> THE ACTS THROWING
LEGEND LOVING LAMAR JACKSON.
YOU KNOW THAT WE LOVE LAMAR
JACKSON ON THIS SHOW.
GREG, DOES THIS GET YOU OFF OF
THAT DAVANTE ADAMS THING?
WHAT DO YOU THINK HERE?
>> OH.
ABSOLUTELY, CONNOR.
DO YOU SEE THAT PLUS 125?
LAMAR JACKSON?
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LAMAR
JACKSON OVER HERE.
MVP CANDIDATE, LAMAR JACKSON.
WE KNOW IT IS RUSHING, WE KNOW
WHAT LAMAR DOES.
HE CAN SLING IT, AND RUN THE
BALL.
THEY ARE TAKING ON CINCINNATI,
TAKING CINCINNATI ON.
I COULD SEE THIS BEING A HIGH
SCORING AFFAIR.
AND I WILL TAKE MY CHANCES,
CONNOR.
IF LAMAR JACKSON IS PLUS MONEY
TO SCORE A TOUCHDOWN RUSHING, I
WILL TAKE THOSE CHANCES.
AND, YOU KNOW WHAT WE COULD DO
OVER HERE?
I THINK I WILL LEAN TOWARDS
THIS MONEY.
ALTHOUGH DAVANTE ADAMS IS A
SAFER PICK.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU RIDING, QATAR?
>> I AM TRAILING YOU, TAKING
MORE OF A RISK HERE.
CRAZY ODDS.
I THINK LAMAR, PLUS 125, A
DIVISION GAME.
HE ALWAYS PUTS THE TEAM ON HIS
BACK IN THOSE BIG MOMENTS.
THE BENGALS ARE NO PUSHOVER
THIS YEAR.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE A TOUGH
TEAM, THEY WILL NOT PLAY OVER
AND DIE IN THIS GAME, WHICH
MEANS LAMAR WILL HAVE TO DO A
LITTLE EXTRA.
YOU SEE WHAT THAT BACKFIELD
LOOKS?
LIKE LE'VEON BELL, ELEVATED
FROM THE PRACTICE SQUAD, THIS
IS WHERE WE ARE AT IN
BALTIMORE.
>> I LIKE LAMAR IN THE END.
ZONE WE DID IT LAST WEEK, WE
ASKED OUR COMMENTERS TO FOLLOW
US ON THAT COOPER CUPP TRAIN.
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE SCORED TWICE.
LET'S DO IT AGAIN, LAMAR
JACKSON, COMING FOR THE RIDE.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE THINKING
RIGHT NOW?
>> COME ON.
CONNOR?
YOU JUST PREACHED.
IT IS SUNDAY, AND IT IS
MORNING.
CHURCH IS IN SERVICE.
CONNOR, YOU JUST PREACHED TO
THE PEOPLE.
AND THEY ARE ALL ROCKING WITH
LAMAR JACKSON.
THEY ARE ALL ROCKING WITH LAMAR
JACKSON.
I SEE ROLAND HARD 45.
COME ON, EASY.
LAMAR JACKSON, NO WHITE SOCKS.
HE'S HOOKING IT TO THE END
ZONE.
WINNERS ONLY,.
PLEASE EL JAY ALL DAY ZACK 18.
CONNOR, YOU JUST SPOKE THE WORD
OF THE PEOPLE, AND THEY ARE
RESPONDING.
>> SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY I
JUST MENTIONED.
I WILL GIVE OUT ONE MORE.
JIMMY 16?
JIMMY 16, HE IS ROCKING WITH
DAVANTE ADAMS.
AND WE SHOWED NO DISCRIMINATION
HERE.
YOU ARE ROCKING WITH A HOODIE.
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
WE ARE RIDING WITH LAMAR
JACKSON, THE ACTS LEGEND.
AND MY GUY, W TRAMMEL TO MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT ROUND.
>> YES, WE ARE IN THIS
TOGETHER.
2ND ROUND BELONGS TO W TRAMMEL.
HE HAS GOT ONE MORE CONTENDER
TO TAKE ON.
THIS IS WHERE THINGS WANT TO
GET INTERESTING.
YOU WANT TO TAKE THAT JERSEY?
YOU WANT TO BE THE SQUAD RIDE
LEADER FOR THIS WEEK NUMBER 7?
WINNER TAKES ALL.
LET'S GET INTO IT NEXT, CHASE
HOWARD ZERO.
LET'S SEE THAT PICK, CHASE?
♪ ♪ ♪
MY MAN, MAKING A COMPLETE MESS
ON THAT STAIRCASE, GOING WITH
TRAVIS KELCE.
MAN, WE HAVE GOT A GOOD MATCH
UP HERE.
TRAVIS KELCE IS ALWAYS A
FAVORITE ON THAT SHOW, WHEN WE
SHOW THE LEADERBOARD AT THE
TOP.
LAMAR, HE GETS IT DONE WEEK
AFTER WEEK.
GREG?
ACTS LEGEND?
STAIRCASE LEGEND?
DO YOU FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT
EITHER ONE?
WHAT HAVE WE GOT HERE?
>> THIS ONE WAS TOUGH, CONNOR.
THIS WAS TOUGH.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IS
TO GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND
LET US KNOW, THIS IS THE LAST
ROUND.
WHEN WE ROCK WITH TRAVIS KELCE,
WE ROCK WITH LAMAR JACKSON.
3-0, WE NEED TO KEEP THIS TRAIN
GOING.
WE NEED TO KEEP THIS TRAIN
CONNOR?
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS, AND A
QUESTION FOR YOU.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO REPLY TO ME
IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW.
I AM GIVING OUT A HOODIE, BUT I
WANT TO KNOW THE OVER UNDER 4
ATTEMPTS THAT IT TOOK THE STARE
LEGEND TO ACTUALLY MAKE THIS
VIDEO?
I WILL SET THE LINE, LET'S SAY
AT 7?
LET US SAY 7?
YOU GUYS TELL ME OVER, UNDER IN
THE COMMENTS?
CONNOR, YOU THINK THEY WENT
OVER OR UNDER?
>> OVER, WAY TOO MANY IS YOUR
ANSWER, THAT PROBABLY TOOK,
THAT IS OKAY, RIGHT?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, TRAVIS
KELCE SCORED ONCE IN THE LAST 4
WEEKS, HE IS STILL AT MINUS
150.
TITANS DEFENSE?
NOT GOOD.
CHIEFS HAVE TO BE HUNGRY.
TRAVIS KELCE NEEDS TO GET INTO
THE END ZONE IT TODAY.
THAT BEING SAID, THOSE MINUS
ODDS, GREG?
I AM STICKING WITH LAMAR OVER
HERE.
I LIKE THE PLUS ODDS, I KNOW
THE MAGIC YOU CAN WORK TO BUMP
THOSE THINGS UP.
WHERE ARE THE COMMENTS AT RIGHT
NOW IT'S DISK SIDE THE SQUAD
RIDE LEADER?
>> COMMENTS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
SO I WILL GIVE OUT SOME
HOODIES.
HERE WE, GO JACK ZANE SAYS
TRAVIS KELCE, SHOUT OUT TO YOU,
JACK.
I SEE TRASH, TRY IN THE
COMMENTS SAYING LAMAR IS A LOCK,
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, TRASH.
RAYMOND RAYMOND FACTS 22,
RAYMOND FACT 22 SAYS TRAVIS
KELCE.
I SEE LAMAR, BRAD SHORT MAN,
BRAD SHORT MAN SAYS LAMAR.
ALL RIGHT, CONNOR IT IS BACK
AND FORTH.
I ALSO SEE PEOPLE SAYING OVER.
THEY ARE SAYING OVER IN THE
COMMENTS.
SO I WILL SAY, SHAQ 2023, I
DON'T THINK I SAID THAT NAME
TODAY, SHAQ 23, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
BUT CONNOR, THE NEXT ONE I SEE,
THE COMMENTS ARE ABOUT TO
CLOSE.
THE NEXT ONE, LET'S CALL IT THE
WINNER, ALL RIGHT?
THE NEXT ONE I SEE, WE WILL
CALL IT THE WINNER.
AND WE GOT EJWYN387 SAYING
LAMAR JACKSON IS A LOT.
SO, THE ACTS LEGEND, LAMAR
JACKSON, AND OUR GUY W TRAMMEL
IS THE WINNER OF SQUAD RIDE
THIS WEEK.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU W TRAMMEL.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU ACTS LEGEND,
AND SHOUT OUT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WROTE WITH THEM.
CAN I SEE THAT GRAPHIC, PLEASE?
SO I COULD SHOW THE PEOPLE WHAT
WE COULD DO HERE?
YOU GUYS SEE LAMAR JACKSON IS
AT PLUS 125?
LET'S SHOW YOU GUYS SOME MAGIC.
PROOF.
>> THERE IT IS!
PLUS 165.
THANKS TO OUR FRIENDS AT DRAFT
KINGS.
WE WILL BOOST THAT FOR YOU GUYS,
WE WILL DO THAT.
WE WILL TELL YOU FROM PLUS 125,
2 PLUS 165.
CHECK B/R BETTING SOCIAL TO OUR
LINK.
SEND US A SCREENSHOT OF YOUR
BETS.
LET'S GET RICH THIS SUNDAY.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS, AND YOUR
CELEBRATIONS.
WE WANT WINNERS, AND WINNERS
ONLY, PLEASE.
>> ALL RIGHT EVERYBODY.
COME ALONG FOR THE RIDE, LET'S
MAKE SOME MONEY AND GET LAMAR
IN THE END ZONE.
LOVE THOSE BOOSTED ODDS, GREG.
WE HAVE GOT MORE.
MORE LOCKS, STILL HAVE THAT
JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY.
IT IS TIME FOR THE COMMENT
CONTEST.
WE DO THIS EVERY WEEK.
IF YOU HANG OUT ON THE B/R
BETTING COMMUNITY STREAM, THE
BETTING APP, WE ASK YOU EVERY
WEEK, HOW MANY YARDS WILL
PATRICK MAHOMES THROW FOR
AGAINST THAT TITANS DEFENSE?
PICK 2 OF OUR FAVORITE
COMMENTS.
LET'S NOT FORGET, THE LINE IS
SET AT 328.5.
GREG, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
THE PEOPLE ARE THINKING IN THE
COMMENTS THAT WE CHOSE FROM
MAHOMES PASSING YARDS?
>> YES SIR.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO,
BEFORE WE DO THAT, GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME, HOW MANY
YARDS YOU THINK MAHOMES IS
THROWING FOR AFTER THE GAME, WE
WILL PICK ONE PERSON WHO
GUESSED CORRECTLY, OR WHO GETS
THE CLOSEST, ACTUALLY.
WE WILL THEN HOOK YOU UP WITH A
SWAG BAG FROM B/R BETTING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE FIRST
COMMENT FROM SOBAN18.
♪ ♪ ♪
THERE IT IS, HE SAYS, SINCE
THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO STOP
--
HE WILL NEED TO PUT UP 382.
382?
I MEAN, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
PAT MAHOMES, OVER.
HERE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PAT
MAHOMES.
THAT 382 SEEMS LIGHT TO ME,.
CONNOR WHICH WAY ARE YOU
LEANING?
IS THAT A LOT OR A LITTLE?
>> NOT AS CRAZY AS PEOPLE
THINK.
2019, LAST TIME HE SAW THE
TITANS IN THE REGULAR SEASON,
HE THREW FOR 446.
I KNOW IT WILL BE DIFFERENT IN
THE PLAYOFFS, BUT 446, THE LAST
TIME WE SAW THEM IN THE REGULAR
SEASON.
THEY NEED HIM TO DO THIS, GREG.
THEY NEED HIM TO GO TOWARDS 400
PASSING YARDS IN THIS GAME TO
KEEP UP WITH THAT TITANS GROUND
ATTACK.
SO I DO NOT THINK IT IS AT ALL
CRAZY.
WHAT IS THE OTHER COMMENT
LEANING?
UNDER?
WAY UNDER?
WHERE ARE WE AT WITH THE NEXT
ONE HERE?
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
NEXT COMMENT FROM VALV56.
VALV56 SAYS, 336 PASSING YARDS
FOR MAHOMES?
>> A LITTLE LOWER?
>> AND, TAKING HOME THE L,
CONNOR.
DO NOT FORGET ABOUT THE 2ND
PART, IN TAKING HOME THE L.
336 IS REALLY LIGHT, REAL
LIGHT.
I DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THE L?
I AM STAYING AWAY FROM THE GAME,
BUT I LIKE THE TOTAL.
SEE, THIS IS A HIGH SCORING
GAME, CONNOR.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON MY GUY
VALV56'S COMMENT?
>> I LIKE, GET BOTH COMMENTS
WERE OVER, RIGHT?
THE LINE WAS 328 POINT, 5
VALV56 WENT A LITTLE BIT OVER
THAT, I THINK THAT IS CLOSER.
382 WOULD SHOCK ME.
BECAUSE IT'S MAHOMES?
NO.
WE ARE LOOKING AT SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN 3 AND A 30 AND 345?
THAT IS MORE REALISTIC.
AND THEY WILL HAVE TO DO IT.
ONCE AGAIN, TO STAY IN THIS
GAME.
I KNOW WE ARE LAUGHING SAYING,
HE HAS TO HOLD THE L AFTER THE
GAME.
I DO NOT BET AGAINST PATRICK
MAHOMES.
GREG, I AM WITH YOU.
THIS IS A DICEY GAME WITH A
BIZARRE LINE.
THE CHIEFS LOVE TO RUN IT UP
WHEN THEY GET A LEAD.
CAN THEY AGAINST DERRICK HENRY?
THAT'S WHAT WE DO NOT KNOW.
WHAT DO THE PEOPLE THINK OF ALL
OF THIS?
>> CONNOR, I AM SEEING A LOT OF
YARDS.
A LOT OF YARDS FROM THESE
PEOPLE, THEY ARE REFERRING TO
MY GUY, PATRICK MAHOMES.
WE HAVE GOT JACQUIZZ AMON 3
OTHER 27 YARDS, BRING HOME THE
W.
IT APPEARS, IS THAT UNDER?
327?
>> A YARD UNDER?
>> BARELY, BARELY, BARELY!
SHOUT OUT TO YOU JACK XIMINES.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
POSITIVE VIBES ONLY.
I LOVE THIS COMMENT, CONNOR.
POSITIVE VIBES ONLY, MAHOMES
WITH THE W, 412 YARDS.
JERSEY OR BUST, 2021?
YOU ARE A LEGEND JERSEY OR BUST
2021.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
THE 2 PEOPLE WHO I SAID, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE?
I DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THE L, I DO
NOT KNOW ABOUT THE L, CONNOR,
THE AUDIENCE LIKES A HIGHER
NUMBER.
SO I SEE 417, 417.
I SEE 428.
THE AUDIENCE LIKES A HIGH
NUMBER.
SO WE ARE GOING TO GO WITH
SOBAN18.
WE WILL GO WITH SOBAN18, AS THE
WINNER OF THE COMMENTS CONTEST.
SOBAN18, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
REMEMBER, AFTER THE GAME, WE
PICK ONE PERSON WHO GUESSED THE
CLOSEST, AND WE HOOK YOU UP
WITH A SWAG BAG.
FILL THOSE COMMENTS UP, KEEP
GUESSING BECAUSE YOU MIGHT HAVE
A CHANCE TO WIN A SWAG BAG.
>> WE CAN'T CLOSE OUT THE SHOW
WITHOUT OUR BOLDEST BETS.
BOLDEST BETS, LET'S GET BACK ON
TRACK, LET'S GET CRAZY, GO FOR
THOSE LONG SHOTS.
GREG, LET THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE IN STORE OVER HERE?
>> OKAY.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
AND LET ME KNOW IF YOU ARE
RIDING WITH ME OR IF YOU ARE
RIDING WITH MY GUY, CONNOR.
CONNOR HAS HIT A COUPLE OF OF
THESE.
HE HAS HAD A COUPLE OF THESE.
SO, CONNOR, TALK TO THE PEOPLE
AND TELL THEM, WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> WE ARE ROLLING WITH JOSH
JACOBS THIS WEEK.
THE GUY, HE CAN SCORE IN
BUNCHES.
AND I THINK AGAINST THE EAGLES
WHO HAVE GIVEN UP A LOT AGAINST
RUNNING BACKS THIS YEAR, I
THINK THIS IS THE WEEK FOR JOSH
JACOBS.
HE EVEN SAID IT THIS WEEK, HE
FINALLY FEELS HIS BEST, LIKE
HIS INJURIES ARE NOT BRINGING
HIM DOWN.
HE FEELS HEALTHY, HE FEELS
RIGHT.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT WANTS TO
RUN THE FOOTBALL.
PLUS, 50?
WHAT, FOR A WORKHORSE RUNNING
BACK?
I DO NOT KNOW.
MAYBE I AM TOO OPTIMISTIC.
LAST HALF CALL, SUNDAY MORNING,
WHO KNOWS WHAT IT IS?
JOSH JACOBS PLUS 650, GETTING
IN THE END ZONE TWICE.
LET'S MAKE IT HAPPEN.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU HAVE IN SCORE?
>> CONNOR.
I WILL TAKE A PLAY OUT OF YOUR
OLD PLAYBOOK, RIGHT HERE.
OLD PLAYBOOK, AND I AM GOING TO
GO WITH MY GUY TYREEK HILL TO
SCORE 2 OR MORE TOUCHDOWNS IN
THIS WEEK'S MATCHUP AGAINST THE
TENNESSEE TITANS.
CONNOR, WE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
A HIGH SCORING AFFAIR?
I SAID I LIKE THE TOTAL, I LIKE
THE OVER.
YOU TALKED ABOUT IT AND SAID IT
WOULD BE A HIGH SCORING AFFAIR.
SO, WHY NOT TYREEK GETTING TO?
THAT IS ONE OF PATRICK MAHOMES
COMFORT BLANKETS.
IT IS HIM, OR TRAVIS KELCE.
TYREEK, GO OUT THERE AND DO
WHAT YOU DO.
CONNOR RAN THIS PLAY A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO.
SO, LET'S RUN IT BACK!
LET'S RUN IT BACK, TYREEK, GO
GET TO!
>> I LOVE.
IT I THINK IT IS ON THE MONEY,
THAT TITANS DEFENSE.
WE SAW PLENTY OF RECEIVERS KIND
OF HEAT THEM UP THIS YEAR.
I DO NOT THINK THEY ARE CRAZY
AT ALL.
2 THINGS WE NEED FROM YOU GREG,
BEFORE WE GO WATCH SOME
FOOTBALL.
NUMBER ONE, WE NEED YOU TO LET
US KNOW WHO THE PEOPLE ARE
ROCKING WITH.
AND THEN MOST IMPORTANT IN THE
SHOW, WHAT JERSEY WILL YOU GIVE
AWAY?
>> GOT A JERSEY TO GIVE A WAY?
GOT A JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY?
CHRIS PAUL G.O.A.T. SAYS JOSH
JACOBS IS A, LOT HE IS ROCKING
WITH YOU, CONNOR.
ROCKING WITH YOU, SHOUT OUT TO
YOU, CHRIS PAUL G.O.A.T..
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
JESSE BALL ON US, RIDING WITH
GREG.
LET'S GET THAT W.
LET'S GET THAT W, TYREEK.
THE COMMENTS ARE BACK AND FORTH,
SHOWING BOTH OF US LOVE,
CONNOR.
THEY ARE SHOWING BOTH OF US
LOVE, BUT IT IS TIME.
IT IS TIME TO GIVE THAT JERSEY
AWAY.
IT IS TIME TO GIVE AWAY THAT
JERSEY.
I AM NOW IN THE COMMENTS,
LOOKING FOR A TAKE, LOOKING FOR
A TAKE.
HERE WE GO, IN THE COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
WE SMITH 44 SAYS, ROCKING WITH
G MONEY AND TYREEK.
THE CHEETAH HILL HAS A LOT OF
EMOJIS, A LOT OF FIRE EMOJIS, A
LOT OF MONEY EMOJIS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU FOR YOUR
EMOJIS, AND YOUR TAKE.
AND ROCKING WITH MY GUY, TYREEK
HILL.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
>> MAN, I AM EXCITED FOR THIS
WEEK.
ONE OF THE LONG SHOT BETS?
BOTH OF THEM HIT, THAT WOULD BE
PRETTY HIGH ON THIS SHOW.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS,
EVERYONE.
LET'S MAKE SOME MONEY TODAY.
CONGRATS TO OUR HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
IF YOU WANT, YOUR BET WILL BE
THERE IN THE NEXT 24 HOURS.
HAVE NO FEAR.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY WHO
COMMENTED.
THANK YOU TO THE LOCK LEGENDS
JOHN HURDLE, JONES W TRAMMEL,
CHASE HOWARD, BRINGING THE HEAT,
WITH THOSE VIDEOS.
ENJOY YOUR FOOTBALL SUNDAY
DRAFT, YOU ARE REALTIME TAKES
IN THE BETTING COMMUNITY STREAM
IN THE B/R BETTING.
>> CONNOR, BEFORE WE GET OUT
OF.
HERE I HAVE TO GIVE OUT ONE
MORE, BROTHER.
ONE MORE FOR JASON WEIGHED.
JAYSON WADE SAYS, JASON WAITED
13 SAYS LOVE THE PICK, BUT
TYREEK IS NOT FULLY HEALTHY.
SO LET'S GO WITH CONNOR!
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, JASON WEIGHED!
YOU ARE ROCKING WITH MY GUY,
CONOR!
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I LOVED CONOR'S PICK, ACTUALLY.
>> STICK AROUND, SHOW A LITTLE
LOVE TO BOTH PICKS, THEN YOU
MIGHT JUST WIN ALONGSIDE GREG
IVORY, MY NAME IS CONNOR
ROGERS.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK, SAME TIME,
SAME PLACE.
LET'S GO 4-0 IN THE LAST 4
WEEKS.
GOOD, BY EVERYONE!
>> YES SIR!
♪ ♪ ♪